[Music]
which most of us titan is the oldest
there is a lot of conflicting ideas on
this issue the premise that super
species have existed since the dawn of
time or more precisely since the permian
triassic mass extinction event but there
are certain titans that are more recent
than the others for example kong or
behemoth so let's take a look at this
topic from an evolutionary science point
of view and also from our estimates and
mind you from the estimate sides they
are our theories and not canon to the
monsterverse so yeah let's get to it
let's start with the youngest individual
even though her species has been in
existence for millions of years
she isn't and although she has a genetic
shared memory mothra was just a few
weeks old when she hatched out from her
egg and transformed into a full-grown
moth from her larval form in a few days
time but sadly she died during the
battle against ghidorah she was only a
few weeks old at that time
next we have the murals these two
specimens that fought godzilla in 2014
hatched from their cocoons inside the
body of dagon in 1999 and were only 15
years old by the time they faced off
with the g-man in san francisco
sadly they were killed but the female
could have grown or transformed into a
queen muto or even the prime a muto
prime given enough time
then we have gong kong was a young ape
by the time gunpei and marlow crashed
landed on skull island in 1945.
this means that he was born around the
19th century but the exact date isn't
known he was just an adult him during
the events of gong skull island and so
he must be around 100 plus to 150 years
old by the time of godzilla vs kong
fully grown with a majestic beard
then next we have the false king king
ghidorah it isn't known as to how old
this individual is but it was recorded
by the ancients
that he came from the stars and with
that assessment of humans noting down
his origins it means that he landed on
earth when we as a species have evolved
that means less than a hundred thousand
years old at the most but he might also
be way older from where he came from
the warbat titans that were seen in the
hollow earth during godzilla vs kong
were two gigantic serpent-like titans
that had very similar traits to a cobra
maybe just outward appearance of the
head and neck nevertheless it was a
snake titan and when did cobras actually
evolve well sometime around 7 to 10
million years ago and yeah robots
maybe have evolved from cobras around 7
to 10 million years ago
then we have the hulking mammoth sloth
titan that is behemoth so as he is a
combo of these genus of mammals who
evolve on earth during the cenozoic era
around 30 to 50 million years ago we can
also estimate that this titan evolved
from either one of them around that same
time so
behemoth
30 to 50 million years old
next we come to camazotz this bad titan
was the main enemy of kong during the
events of kingdom kong just before skull
island was engulfed by a perpetual storm
camazotz as we said was a bad titan and
bats evolved around 40 to 50 million
years ago that means he is an offshoot
from a species from a range of species
that arose during that time so camazotz
40 to 50 million years old
the next on this list is the hyper
carnivorous super species called the
skull crawlers these gigantic creatures
were not like the other titans that fed
on radiation so it had to evolve later
on after the main ones went into
hibernation our guess would be that
these creatures arrive on the scene some
60 to 70 million years ago and maybe
caused the extinction of the dinosaurs
with their hyper carnivorous state
so next we have the fire demon rodan
rodan is a reptilian tyrant who shares
many similarities with the pterodactyls
and the pteranodons of the mesozoic era
since the earliest recorded specimen of
the pteranodon is around 90 to 100
million years ago we can also guess that
this flying titan evolved from one of
them around that same time around 90 to
100 million years old
next we have the muto prime this was a
highly evolved form of the normal female
muto and even though the queen muto was
maybe the old mature specimen of the
female of their species this one prime
would have been pretty old and able to
take down a godzilla specimen when fully
energized and with relative ease so this
individual prime
would have been very old could have been
close to around the same age as the
g-man himself around 252 million years
old
then next there are four talents that
share maybe a similar age and these are
the shinomura the ocean queen thailand
called tiamat the armoured squid titan
seller and godzilla himself
these titans were definitely one of the
oldest evolving before the permian
triassic extinction event some 252
million years ago shinamura and godzilla
are known to have fought each other
during that time so these two are pretty
much of the same age
the other two well
let us just say that they are educated
guesses in quotes
on the second spot we have three titans
which have been placed as the second
oldest ones
mind you again this is our estimate
not canon to the movie universe but you
can bring up your own conclusions in the
comments down there well methuselah
comes here on this spot since he was
named after the oldest living human ever
which is methuselah and yeah maybe
because he is really old the titan then
we have titanosamhulu who is essentially
just a nervous system a vertebrate one
of the earliest vertebrates that
kinetically formed a body from woods and
trees
and lastly we have nakika titanic nakika
who is a cephalopod and it would have
evolved from the earliest octopus
ancestors around 300 plus million years
ago
and yeah we have placed a hulu as well
as methuselah in the same timeframe 300
plus million years old
and the oldest iron is maybe the janitor
alpha this species absolutely is huge if
compared to the fish species it evolved
from
it came from a dunkleosteus which
appeared on earth around 350 to 380
million years ago
it unfortunately died in an encounter
with godzilla which means that in those
millions of years of its existence
it has not encountered godzilla before
therefore giving it the balls to
challenge him and die
anyway with that we come to the end of
it tell us what you think if you agree
or not so do hit that like button
support us subscribe us and smash the
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos on this channel till the next one
take care fam